Stan Lee is a pop culture titan.
With a career that spans eight decades, he’s
been around long enough to see characters
he co-created become household names, a roster
that includes Spider-Man, the X-Men, the Hulk,
and more.
His journey has been remarkable, but it might
not be what you’d expect from the smiling
spokesman for Marvel Comics.
Stan “The Delivery Man” Lieber
Lee was born Stanley Martin Lieber, the son
of Jewish immigrants from Romania.
As a student, he worked odd jobs to help his
family get through the tail end of the Great
Depression, including delivering sandwiches
in Manhattan, a far cry from his dreams of
writing sci-fi novels.
Not long after graduating high school at 16,
however, he got a job at a company run by
one of his relatives, Martin Goodman... a
little place called Timely Comics.
Stan Lieber No More!
When he joined up with Timely Comics in 1939,
Stan Lieber thought that his job as an errand
boy would be a stepping stone to a career
as a novelist.
Needless to say, things turned out a little
differently.
In 1941, Stan was assigned to write a text-only
story as filler for Captain America Comics
#3.
For this story, "Captain America Foils the
Traitor's Revenge," he used the pseudonym
Stan Lee, intending to save his real name
for his future career as a serious novelist.
Within months, the imaginative new kid was
off creating superheroes of his own, with
names like Jack Frost and Father Time.
Just before Lee turned 19, Captain America’s
creators, Joe Simon and Jack Kirby, left over
a dispute with Goodman, and Lee was named
interim editor.
Before his career could really take off, though,
World War II would force him into a brief
detour.
Soldier Stan
Stan Lee joined the U.S. Army in 1942, where
his talent with words led to assignments writing
training manuals and slogans for posters.
Before long, he ended up in the Army's Training
Film Division writing scripts, and, as he
would later recount, he was one of only nine
people in the entire Army whose title was
listed as "playwright."
While serving in the army, Stan continued
to send in scripts for Timely’s popular
titles, and when the war ended, Lee, only
23 years old, reclaimed the job as editor,
and wouldn't give it up for decades.
But not before thinking about quitting entirely...
Reinventing Superheroes
By the 1950s, controversy over the content
in comic books had been raging for years,
to the point where publishers like MAD Magazine’s
Bill Gaines were called to testify before
the senate.
The result was the Comics Code, a strict set
of regulations that put several publishers
out of business, and limited the kinds of
stories creators could tell.
Faced with declining sales, a lack of respect
for comics, and the restrictions of the Code,
Lee was demoralized enough to quit.
Fortunately, his wife Joan convinced him to
try something new.
Inspired by their competition’s recent success
with putting their biggest heroes into a team
book called Justice League of America, Stan
formed a team of is own, partnering with Jack
Kirby to create the Fantastic Four.
In November of 1961, the rebranded Marvel
Comics launched with Fantastic Four #1, introducing
readers to a superhero team that combined
sci-fi origins with relatable personalities.
In between battling supervillains and interdimensional
threats, the team bickered, fought, and acted
like you'd expect regular, flawed people with
superpowers to act.
The immediate success led Goodman to order
basically as many new characters and comic
books as Lee, Kirby, and the other Marvel
artists could come up with.
Before long, the Marvel Bullpen was known
to the world, with Stan “The Man” Lee’s
jovial editorials making him the friendly
face of the Marvel Age of Comics.
Amazing Fantasies
As a kid, Stan Lee had been a fan of a pulp
magazine character called the Spider, which
gave him the idea to approach Goodman about
introducing a teen character with spider-themed
powers.
Lee would later recall that this idea was
met with some pretty big skepticism from Goodman.
“Nobody wanted me to do it!
My publisher, when I suggested the idea, he
said, ‘That’s the worse thing I ever heard
of.’”
“Why?”
“People hate spiders!”
Rather than risking a whole new series on
the wild idea, Lee instead decided to try
his character out in Amazing Fantasy, a series
that was due to be canceled anyway.
With Kirby proving to be a bad fit for the
character, artist Steve Ditko took a crack
at it instead, and the world was introduced
to Peter Parker, the Amazing Spider-Man.
After Amazing Fantasy #15 went flying off
the shelves, Spidey was quickly given his
own series, paving the way for another wave
of Marvel heroes.
Marvel hits Hollywood
By the 21st century, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe would be breaking box office records,
but Marvel’s, and Stan’s, original road
to Hollywood was actually a lot more difficult
than they expected.
In the '70 s, there were plenty of attempts
at bringing Marvel properties to television.
The Amazing Spider-Man debuted on CBS as a
TV movie in 1977, and while the technical
limitations were obvious, fans seemed thrilled
to have a live-action version of the webslinger
airing in prime time.
It didn’t last, though.
CBS pulled the plug after 13 episodes because
of its more successful Marvel adaptation,
The Incredible Hulk.
Featuring Bill Bixby as Dr. Banner and Lou
Ferrigno as his rampaging alter ego, The Incredible
Hulk aired for five seasons, and helped to
cement the character in the pop culture consciousness.
Unfortunately, the attempts at launching Doctor
Strange and Captain America through TV movies
didn’t work out, and Marvel’s hard luck
got worse when the entire comics industry
hit a slump in the ‘90s.
Through it all, though, Stan continued to
be an ambassador for the brand, and while
it had been years since he’d actually been
an editor at Marvel, a new wave of Marvel
films in 2000 led to what has today become
his signature: the well-placed cameo.
“Superheroes in New York?
Gimme a break.”
The face of Marvel
Since the beginning of Marvel's rise to pop
culture dominance over 50 years ago, Stan
Lee's face and personality have only grown
more associated with the brand.
He's lent his voice to video games and cartoons,
appeared in almost every Marvel movie, and
even writes the occasional new comics story
for Marvel.
It all became possible because a creative
kid with an illustrious background in sandwich
delivery and a struggling young industry took
a chance on each other, and because of Joan
Lee, the greatest advice-giver there ever
was.
Excelsior!
“You know, I guess one person can make a
difference.
Nuff said.”